(calm music)
- Welcome to "Ear Biscuits",
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a
long time, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link, this week
at the round table of dim lighting.
we're going to pull back the
curtain on all of the ideas
that we've had for traditional projects.
I'm talking about scripted
television, movies,
non-scripted television,
animated projects,
We have so many ideas
that we've come up with over the years
and we've pursued a lot of them
and some of them went a long ways.
But a lot of the,
basically everything
we're going to talk about
has never seen the light of day.
- Until today.
- And I just thought it would be fun
for us to share with you
all of these specific ideas
we've had that encapsulate
a percentage of what our
collective creative dreams are, you know?
- I would say a significant
percentage of time,
and also of aspiration.
And we might, I don't
know, this may end up
being a two-part thing where we talk
a little bit more about like the personal,
like dealing with rejection.
We'll see how far we get into that.
I think there's a whole
conversation to be had around
dealing with rejection and failure.
- I agree, 'cause I was
actually wondering like,
is this actually going to be depressing
to revisit all these ideas
that just died on the vine or fizzled out?
And I want to keep this fun,
but I do think there is a reality to
weathering a ton of rejection.
- Yeah, well, and I think
that we say this a lot, that,
you know, you may wonder sometimes,
I mean, there is a lot of
things that you see, right?
You see this podcast, you
see "Good Mythical Morning",
"Good Mythical More", you
see all the other stuff
that Mythical Entertainment puts out
and we're involved in a lot of things.
And then some things you do see,
like when "The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek"
or "The Book of Mythicality
or "Buddy System",
there are other things
throughout the years
that have seen the light of day,
have gone through the full
birth of the creative process
and birthed out into the world.
But when you ask yourself,
what do you guys,
what exactly do you do?
Well, besides the things that you see
we do spend a very significant
portion of our time
trying to make things happen
through other avenues.
And I'll just set it up just quickly
to not get too much into this, but like,
okay, yeah, you have this YouTube channel,
you have this audience,
you have people who are
willing to watch and listen to
the things that you create.
So why are you spending your time
trying to make, say, a
television, a movie, or whatever
when there's no-
- Not make but sell.
- Yeah, when there's no guarantee
that anybody's ever going to see it.
And is it, do you feel inferior
because you're only making
stuff for a digital audience
and you're not being able
to do the traditional thing.
I mean, there's definitely, for me,
a sort of a chip on my shoulder
of not being able to work on those things
that are the things that kind of
I personally enjoy a little bit more.
I enjoy traditional TV and movies
more than I enjoy watching YouTube videos.
That's just me personally
and how I spend most of
my time being entertained.
But it's less, for me that's
kind of a small portion of it.
And it's really more that we're limited
in the kinds of stories that we can tell
and the kinds of things
that we can explore
through the YouTube medium just because,
you know, you have to create content
that can make a business,
can run a business
and can be a profitable thing.
It's like we talked about for
years with "Buddy System",
like we were glad we had the opportunity
to make "Buddy System"
because we finally got paid.
- People would complain about
why it was on YouTube Red,
everybody couldn't see it.
- Now everyone can see it, but.
- Yeah, it's free now for anyone.
- Years later.
- But at the time that our response was,
we couldn't make a more
ambitious scripted project
with the budgets we are working with
without getting funding from an outlet
that then you got to pay for.
- And when you go through those,
when you go through that process
of developing an idea and taking it out
in the traditional way, you
know, taking it to somebody,
pitching it to a network
or a streamer or whatever,
you run up against something
that's very unusual for us.
Like we, you know, we have
an idea to make this podcast,
we just do it.
We have an idea to make this
episode of this podcast,
we just do it, we just make
the decision and we just do it
and there it is, distributed
to everyone, right?
Ad supported most of the time.
- Every decision associated
with "Good Mythical Morning"
the buck stops with us.
- There's no gate-
- We're in charge.
- There's really no gatekeeper, right?
I mean, sure there's rules and regulations
that you have to abide
by if you want your video
to get served up to
everybody on YouTube, right?
- You cannot eat a mattress
anymore on YouTube.
- If you eat a mattress you have to,
that will get banned and you have to
just give it to the Mythical Society.
But with everything in
the traditional space
there's still the gatekeepers
because this stuff costs
so much more money to make.
They've got the money, they're
holding the purse strings,
and they control the gate
and they control who gets in
the gate and we, you know,
I don't know, I don't even know
how I'll feel about some of these ideas
'cause we're going back at least a decade
and covering a lot of
things that, it's not like,
here, I'll be very clear
before we get into these,
it's not like you're
going to be blown away
with the innovative and
original nature of these ideas
and be like, I can't I believe nobody!
The thing is is that-
- You be, let 'em be the judge.
- But I'm saying that there are
so many talented people in the world
trying to get things made.
And I'm not saying that we've gotten
the raw end of the deal,
I'm just saying it's a difficult thing
when you go through the gatekeepers,
it's a difficult process
and you got to develop,
you've got to develop a thick skin.
- And you got to develop a lot of ideas.
I have a working list in front
of me of what might be 20.
And so I'm going to throw
out just some working titles
and see if you can remember these.
I don't think you're going
to remember all these ideas,
I certainly didn't, I
just had to dig 'em up
in our Google vault.
But let's start with talking about
Today on "Good Mythical More",
we made a decision for
Damnyell to come in.
You know, he hadn't
come in in a long time.
So you stepped away.
- Yeah.
- Damnyell stepped in
and he ended up showing
this sizzle reel for-
- It's quite a bit he had.
- An animated series that
he says that he developed,
okay, yet we developed an animated series
and this is one of the most
recent ideas that fizzled out.
You know, Damnyell said that,
there was a lot of interest,
especially from one network.
And then as we were talking about how,
like the budget and like
getting into details
on how they would fund it and how much
then the entire team that
we've been talking to.
Like they, I don't know, they got fired,
they got restructured.
- This happens all the time.
- It was done away with,
so everyone that we were talking to
no longer worked at the network.
Which kind of means the idea's dead.
I mean, 'cause we had taken
it out to other places
and this was the one place
that was most interested.
So we were like, you know what, screw it.
We made this sizzle reel,
it's a freaking animated thing
in partnership with-
- Cartoona.
Shout out to Cartoona,
sorry I almost forgot.
- I didn't, I didn't forget.
- I won't forget you Cartoona,
we'll work with you again
but we're like, they put a
lot of good work into this,
it was all speculative.
Everybody spend a little
money, nobody made anything.
Like let's at least show it
to you guys, So that's what,
then we were like, screw it, let's do it.
And now let's talk about it.
It's called "Unattended Baggage".
We're like, let's put Cotton
Candy Randy, Damnyell,
in an environment, let's
put 'em in an airport
where they work, we just thought
it would be funny to like,
even though you could go anywhere
in the world of cartoon animation,
we just thought it was ironic to like-
- Yeah, it was the built-in irony.
- Pin them down in the place
that everybody wants to escape
from and that's an airport.
There's lots of different
places you can work,
there's lots of like
workplace dynamics there.
So we started to build out
what that might look like.
- It was based on the one time
that I think Damnyell and
Cotton Candy Randy got together
in either a GMM or a GM More episode
and we were like, you know,
these guys are so other worldly.
I mean, literally in some ways,
that this seems like the perfect thing
to put them together in an
animated show and you know,
but the idea was okay, so
you got me as Damnyell,
you got Jordan as Cotton Candy Randy,
and then, well,
- I should be in it too.
- You know, this needs to be a trio.
And so the original
idea basically just had
you as kind of a grounded character.
I don't know exactly, your name
may have already been Leroy
but you were essentially Link
and you were using your regular voice
and we actually did a whole, in fact,
the animation and
everything was originally
just you talking in your normal voice.
- Then we got, we got
to get a funnier voice.
This character needs to be funny.
- Too much opportunity for
this character to be funny
and so then you basically ended up
kind of doing your forest patrol voice.
It's essentially the same guy.
- 'Cause as much as people want
forest patrol to come back,
it costs a lot of money to
animate and we couldn't,
we just can't justify or
support that just online.
- Again, you make a certain-
- I'll just take that characterization,
I'll bake it into this character
and we'll see what happens.
- I thought it was a big improvement.
I gotta say, I mean, are we,
listen, I don't want this to be a downer,
but I am going to just be honest with you
as we revisit these
ideas and I still think
that "Unattended Baggage"
could be a great show,
especially in the way that we
kind of developed the pitch
even after we developed the sizzle reel.
But I got to say-
- And we should talk about,
I want to say what that
is because I think that's,
strength of the show is
actually not in the sizzle reel
because we got going, we wrote
something, it was animated,
and then we were like, you know what?
And it was called Fairview,
'cause Fairview International
was the name of the airport.
But then we started to really
dig into the characters
and we were like, I think
there's something about
dealing with masculinity,
toxic masculinity,
stereotypical masculinity,
and guys getting in
touch with their feelings
and their trauma, potentially.
- Well, and every one of
the characters ended up,
it was very clear every
one of the characters
had some baggage, had
some psychological things,
some trauma in their background
that really contributed to who they were
and actually contributed to who they were
and what made them funny.
- So let's play with that,
like within their world,
let's actually grapple with therapy
and what their need for therapy-
- Informally.
- Informally through other characters.
And then we changed the title
to "Unattended Baggage".
- And every episode was going to be,
or not necessarily every episode,
but in many different
episodes it was gonna be often
a device that we were going to use
was going to be a
flashback to the childhoods
of each one of our main three characters
so that you kind of
explore the relationship
with them and their parents
and then how they're as adults
having never properly dealt
with all their unintended baggage as kids
are kind of working that out,
to hilarious ends, as adults.
So that's what the show became,
it's not really captured in the reel.
The sizzle reel was like the
section of the pilot and-
- That's what we were
excited about though,
was when we got into the exploring
the guys and therapy of it all.
- Yeah, I have absolutely no idea.
I'm sure we'll see in the comments
how people will respond to
us showing that to them.
I think people will-
- Well we did it in a way
that was a bit confusing
because it's like, is
this real, was this real?
You know, I thought that was fun.
- Have they really committed
this much to this bit
for him to show this?
- Now you know.
- I think the show would be much better
than the sizzle reel
indicates, but you know,
you be the judge of what
you think this'll be.
- Listen, if those people weren't laid off
we'd be making the show right now.
- 'Cause I also think that they understood
what we were doing and how
it had kinda updated and,
I have mixed feelings about that one
'cause I still feel like
there is a viable show there.
I just don't feel like we
executed the pitch that great
and then of course, things
outside of our control
caused it to fall through.
- Okay, so that was like one
of the more recent ideas.
I want to go back to one of the first
ideas that we came up with.
Now, we're going back to
the "Online Nation" days
so we were coming out here,
we were hosting the show,
you know, basically beginning to host it
as it was already
beginning to be canceled.
One of the producers on the show, Paul,
was basically he became
our defacto manager
because every time we came
out here we were like,
okay, we got ideas.
- We gotta get something else going.
- We got stuff we want to do.
Paul Cockrell, you know,
he was basically the guy
who discovered Pauly shore.
The reason why Pauly shore
was the VJ personality
that he was on MTV was because of Paul.
- And he was instrumental
in basically establishing Los Angeles
as a home for MTV as well, from New York.
'Cause it had basically
been a New York thing.
- Yeah, he was the first L.A. guy.
And then the producer of "Online
Nation" was David Hurwitz
who was an executive
producer on "Fear Factor"
back in the day, you know, years earlier.
- In fact, who famously said to us
while we were hosting
"Online Nation", more energy!
- More energy, that's all he would say.
- More energy!
- But Paul was more hands-on.
- We say that as an inside joke.
- So Paul became our defacto manager
so he was the one that we were talking to
about all these ideas,
scripted and non-scripted,
and he was like, well,
it was like, yeah, we got a scripted idea,
we can write a pilot.
And we went back home
and we wrote what eventually
became we called "Legitimate".
- So that was before the reality ideas or?
- I think at the same time, because-
- Because I've got the
script on my computer
and it says copyright 2012.
- I think at the same time
we were also developing
non-scripted ideas,
we had two of those.
- But we shot-
- But we shot sizzle reels for those.
- Those were before,
because we still lived in North Carolina
'cause I remember being in Lillington,
going around Lillington
shooting some of that stuff.
- That's where we were
when we started writing "Legitimate" too,
so they were happening at the same time.
- Okay, so I guess it
was just 2012 is when-
- We can talk about
the non-scripted stuff,
we had this idea for a reality show,
kind of like "Dirty Jobs",
but instead of Mike Rowe it's
the two of us going around
to like redneck, I mean,
what I call redneck hobbies.
- Lawnmower racing.
- Redneck past times.
Yeah, lawnmower racing, noodling,
that's where you, like you dig
your hand down into a river
and you get a cat fish to eat your hand.
Like we were going to go do these things
and we were like, hey, we
know enough of these people,
we can put something on tape so to speak
that can sell this idea.
'Cause it's like, hey,
we still can tap into
that good old boy nature, you know,
we still live here in Harnett County.
And my dad knew all of these guys
who participated in
competitive lawnmower racing.
And so we went out there
and we got permission
to film the whole thing
and then we started interviewing
guys and like, I mean,
there's some funny moments when we were-
- We participated in the lawnmower race.
- These are not normal lawnmowers,
they're like drag racing
versions of lawnmowers.
And they pull a sled in a straight line,
whoever can get the
furthest the fastest wins.
And yeah, we talked a guy into
letting us ride his lawnmower
in the competition
and we make complete
fools out of ourselves
and it was perfect, in our mind.
- It was funny, I mean, again-
- We called it "Good Old Boys".
- "Good Old Boys", I can't
help but be the, you know,
the 10 year later producer and be like,
oh, the fatal flaw with this idea
was that we assumed that we had the right.
In other words, like, okay,
"Dirty Jobs" and Mike Rowe
of makes sense a little bit,
like it started as he
was like this guy doing
this bit on the radio
and he's this older guy
that's like highlighting
these people in America.
We were just like two
dumb asses who were like
a little bit country, a
little bit rock and roll
and we thought we could go
and just hang out with
rednecks and have fun.
And while I do think it
would have been a funny show,
people at the time were looking
for like, what's your in?
Like why you guys for this thing?
And so it just kind of died on the vine.
- Like maybe it should
be Larry the Cable Guy,
is kind of what you're saying.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But I mean, for the
video version of this thing
we can show you a clip,
we'll dig up the archives.
(engine revving)
At the same time we
developed another pitch,
'cause we told Paul, well, you know,
we also have engineering degrees,
you know, we're smart guys.
We developed a pitch
called "This or That".
- Now this was a good idea.
- We couldn't call it "Would You Rather"
because "Would You Rather" was-
- It's copyrighted.
- Trademarked or whatever it is as a game.
We looked into licensing it,
like Paul looked into that
but like they wouldn't have any part of it
so we just changed it to this or that.
But it was a, as far as I can remember,
we would pick two things.
Well, it was a would you rather scenario.
- It was would you rather-
- That could actually be carried out.
- And we would both do
one side of the thing
and come to the decision
of which one was the
actual correct answer.
- We would actually definitively know
because we've experienced
both sides of it.
- We shot a reel for that too.
- Would you rather-
- There was a fire hose
involved in one scene.
- I think it was, would you rather be
pelted with a full blast of a fire hose
for X number of minutes
or have to walk around town an
entire day completely soaked.
And so then we cut to a shot of one of us
dousing ourselves completely
with water from head to toe,
like boots filling up with
water in the Walmart parking lot
and then walking into Walmart.
So you get an idea of, okay,
camera's going to follow around one of us
who is like constantly soaking himself
and trying to conduct normal life,
maybe get them a mortgage, I don't know.
So it's a bit bitty, kind of sketchy,
but then we also cut to the other person
who was standing in front
of a a fireman with a hose
and he started blasting us with water.
- It was Joey Smith.
- Yeah, 'cause back in Harnett County
you got these connects.
- He was a serving with the Lillington
volunteer fire department and
had access to a fire hose.
And did we actually get sprayed
with a fire hose that day?
Or did we just make it look
like it was about to happen?
I can't remember.
- I'll have to look at the footage.
I'm pretty sure that we
were just far enough away-
- That it wasn't crazy.
- That it wasn't that crazy,
but I might just be making up in my mind.
The footage will tell.
- That particular example that we used
for the pitch is not
great, but the show still-
- There were other examples too.
I think we had two more sets of examples,
but that's a fun idea.
I think we revisited it a few times.
- Maybe as a web series.
- As a web series.
I'm surprised we didn't
pull the trigger on it
'cause it's almost something
that we could do now.
- Well we ended up doing would
you rather as a GMM segment
and that's when I baby birded
things into your mouth,
it was just made the smaller,
more producible version of that.
- The last thing I remember
we did with Paul was
instead of us coming out to L.A. one time,
he said that he was coming
out to Maryland for something.
And he said, you boys need to drive up
because the Discovery
Channel headquarters.
- Silver Springs, Maryland.
- Is in Silver Springs, Maryland,
right on the edge of Washington D.C.
That's where you had to
meet with development
if you wanted to have a show
on the Discovery Channel.
And you know, we really thought
because we had engineering degrees
we should be able to come up with an idea.
Did we take this or that to them?
I think we took a couple of other ideas,
but I remember it being-
- I can't remember all the ideas.
- It was more of a meet
and greet meeting too
where it was like, yeah,
we should work together.
Sometimes it's just, it's
not about the pitches,
It's just about getting to know, like-
- I remember the, I remember an idea
that we pitched to them
and I still, I'm afraid to,
I still think this is a
great idea for a show.
It was our answer to a
man on the street show,
It was our answer to "Cash Cab"
and it was called "Guesstimaters".
- Oh, well yeah, we brought
that back as "The Magic Number",
we'll talk about it later.
- But do you remember, so
the "Guesstimaters" idea,
which yes, we brought
back as a different idea
that was more contained
but the original idea for "Guesstimaters"
was that we would be, and
this is sort of based on,
you know, the thing that
we do on GMM sometimes
which is we try to guess
a number of something.
But this was like, you're on the street
and let's say one episode
takes place in New York City
and so we walk up to
somebody on the street
and we say, sir, right there,
you see the Empire State Building,
how many windows, individual windows
do you think are on the
Empire State Building?
If you can get within 10
you're going to win $1,000 right
now or something like that.
And so then it would be like,
they'd guess and he would
be wrong or he'd be right.
But then there would be this
like graphical sort of like animated thing
where it would be like, here's
the empire state building
and all of a sudden like
animated like overlay on it
would show you like,
there's this many windows
and they're made out of
this and they're this big
and they attach in this
way and there's this many.
- You'd learn all this
stuff through the animation.
But you would also get if
you're one of those people
like you, that really
loves to guesstimate things
and is actually really good at it.
We thought that was another
part of it that's like,
you've always done that
and you've always made me guess things
just so I can look like an idiot.
- Right.
- So it's like that foil, and
this is part of our pitch,
it's like, hey, you're
really good at estimating
and I suck at it so maybe there's a way
to play into that for some comedy.
So yeah, that was a fun idea.
I mean, you have to believe in the ideas
to really pitch 'em.
- In the moment especially.
You can question them later.
- So we've got more of these
but first I just want to
tell you to buy this mug.
- No, no, no, I mean,
you can buy that mug,
but it's the t-shirt.
- Oh, it's not the mug.
Don't buy this mug.
- So this t-shirt,
very special t-shirt.
It is only available
to third degree members
of the Mythical Society,
as is the album that it references.
Of course, this is "Rhett
and Link sing Lionel",
this is the picture on
the front of the album,
which is the latest collectible
item that you can get
as a third degree member
of the Mythical Society.
But if you want the t-shirt
that is associated with it
that comes with our signatures,
I mean, this is a printed signature,
I'm not going to lie to you,
we didn't sign every single one of these,
you have to be a third degree member
to be eligible to purchase it.
So it was a little bit different,
we haven't done this
exclusive purchasable item
within the context of
the Mythical Society,
so super special, super
exclusive, limited time
MythicalSociety.com
- Well go to Mythical.com
to buy the shirt.
- No, but it's only available
for third degree members.
Oh, but you get like a code or something?
- I don't know, yeah,
yeah, you get a code.
Let's just say that.
I don't know, you'll figure it out.
If you're a society member
you'll be able to buy it at Mythical.com.
- Okay.
- "Legitimate" is the pilot
that we conceptualized and
wrote at the same time.
And I swear, I mean,
the first working title
of "Legitimate" was?
- "Musical Therapy".
- "Musical Therapy",
because we were like, hey,
we're musical comedians,
we can write funny songs,
I bet you, we can bake that
into a television show.
And then Paul was like,
yeah, yeah, yeah, do that.
It's like, we'll call
it "Musical Therapy",
he was like, yeah.
And you were like, let's write it.
So we went back to our cave
and then we conceptualize this thing.
And eventually we changed the name of it.
- Because of the name of
the town was Legitimate.
And so we were like, oh, that's
a cool name for, and also,
So, you know, the premise of
the show is that you've got
two guys, usually starts with
two guys for obvious reasons,
who have been in Los Angeles
doing the musical therapy thing,
like actually operating a
musical therapy business
and then there was an accident,
someone accidentally passed away
when they were participating
in the musical therapy
in the hospital.
- That's the opening scene.
- The funny thing is is
it's not the opening scene
in this version that I've got.
I've got a few versions
that I found on Dropbox.
This is what is called a
legitimate pilot draft three.
- Okay.
- And it starts with us in
our office in Legitimate,
but you're right that in my recollection,
the opening scene was in
the hospital in Los Angeles
and we had this dream for Jack Black
to play the patient who dies
in the very opening scene.
- Yeah, because we were meeting
with production companies
to partner with somebody
and we met with Jack
Black's production company.
Jack Black was not there.
- No, he probably never heard about it.
- His development person was there
and we, you know, we gave the whole pitch
and we were like, all right, opening scene
you got this guy who
he's in his hospital bed
and then his musical therapists come in
and they start playing him a song.
And we actually wrote the song.
- 'Cause we sang the song of the pitch.
- And then, 'cause we sang
the song in the pitch.
Like you brought your guitar
and we started singing this
song and it sounded good.
- And he gets so into it
that he's in the hospital
because of a heart condition
and then he gets so into the performance
in the opening scene that he
has a heart attack and dies.
And so we get sued for malpractice,
we lose our Los Angeles
practice and we have to go back
to our hometown of
Legitimate, North Carolina
which is not a real town,
but is basically a Buoys Creek type,
well, a little bit
bigger than Buoys Creek,
maybe a Fuquay situation.
And then the show is about these two guys
who've kind of gone off to L.A.
and become a little bit L.A.-ified
- But then failed.
- And failed and then had
to kind of come back home
with their tail between their legs.
- And no one understands
what musical therapy is.
- And then try to do something
that's very, very L.A.
in a place that's very, very, not L.A.
So they still try to
be musical therapists.
- But the real story, oh
man, it's been so long,
the real story is more about like
me reconnecting with my ex girl,
or my character reconnecting
with his ex girlfriend
who's now pregnant by his father.
- Well, that's a spoiler alert, yeah.
So you get introduced-
- I'm sorry, don't spoil it.
- You get introduced to your ex-girlfriend
and she's pregnant and it's awkward.
And you're kind of like,
ah, you know, like,
you're still single, but
you're kind of interested.
You were interested in her
and kind of this long
lost love kind of thing
and then when you come back she's pregnant
and this is news to you.
And then the final scene of
the pilot it reveals that
she's pregnant with your
father's baby. (laughs)
- Which then sets up the rest
of the season and there's-
- I still love that.
- There's another character, T-Birch,
that a version of
T-Birch made his way into
"The Lost Causes of Bleak Creek".
- Yeah, Travis is a T-Birch character.
- So these things come back to us,
but there's this whole thing
about raiding a sperm bank.
That's the, I mean, I think
we should take this script-
- And that's my, I think
that's my dad in the thing.
He's been getting a lot of
money too for donating sperm
and T-Birch helps us
break into a sperm bank.
- So we, I don't remember why,
but I think we should take this script
and we should post it
on the Mythical Society.
- Well, let me read it one more time.
- Don't you think?
- Let me read it one more time because,
I'm sure that the writing is not great,
just between you and us,
I'm sure the writing is not,
not like all of a sudden
our writing is good now,
I'm just saying, 10 years is a long time.
- All right, so I'm gonna,
do you want to go with
some scripted ideas?
Let's go with some scripted ideas
and come back to non-scripted.
Do you remember any of
these, 'cause I'm moving on.
So, all right, and these
will kind of be out of order.
These are from 2018, we
go through these like-
- Sort of development periods.
- We go through periods where
we have a little bit of time
and we sit down and we come up with like
four, six, 10 ideas.
We bounce them off Stevie.
Sometimes some other people,
we figure out what
we're most excited about
and then we're like, our
agents set up meetings.
- So you're jumping all the way to 2018,
did you skip a bunch of stuff?
- I'm going to go back.
I'm going to skip around, yeah.
- Okay.
- Do you remember T-minus Mars?
- Very well, yeah.
- All right, what do
you remember about it?
- This was a community of people
who were preparing to be
the first colony on Mars
and in preparation to
become the colony on Mars
they had to live in
basically this replica biosphere on Earth
for an indefinite amount
of time as sort of a test,
like a psychological test
and a sort of how well can
they get along with each other
in this space on Earth
and it was paid for by
an eccentric billionaire.
A woman who had gotten all her money
by inventing some ridiculous,
like some kind of weird shoe.
What was it that she had invented?
She had invented a weird
shoe, which incidentally-
- The flip.
- Oh it's a flip-flop that
doesn't make a flip sound.
- Doesn't make a flop sound.
And, yeah, and so she's a
billionaire because of that.
And anyway, it's essentially
an ensemble cast,
sorta like, you know, your
typical half hour comedy.
like "The Office" or whatever,
but they're all inside this thing.
- It's like that Mars show
that came out that had
Tim Heidecker and-
- I never watched that.
- I watched the pilot and it was similar.
It's like there was,
basically it was lot of people
thinking about like Mars colonization
and coming up with TV ideas and-
- But were they on Mars in the show
or are they on Earth?
- They were on Earth and
they were trying to get there
but they were a bunch of misfits.
- Yeah, I mean, similar idea.
- Same idea.
- And to be clear, I'm
not saying it was a,
what do you call it, multiple discovery
is what they call that in science,
it happens all the time
in entertainment where
two people come up with similar ideas.
- It was a bit too obvious.
- I'm sure theirs was better.
- At the same time we
put that one out there
We also put "Beef Queen" out there.
"Beef Queen" is the story of a family
fast-food owned franchise, sorta
like an In-N-Out situation.
And the father is basically
suffering from dementia,
the guy who found it,
sort of like a Ray Crock kind of thing,
Like he founded this incredibly
successful restaurant
and he's on the way out
and his two daughters,
he's handing the business
over to his two daughters
and he's got one daughter
who's like the older daughter
and she's like totally
committed to the vision
and has been on board the entire time
and you've got the flaky, younger sister
who's sort of like this new age hippie
who kind of stands for all this stuff
that is diametrically opposed to-
- Beef.
- Selling hamburgers to everyone
and what that does to the world.
And the husbands of each
one of these, so I played,
I was going to play the husband.
- Maze Hendrix.
- Maze Hendrix who was
sort of the hippie husband
of the younger sister.
- An unaccomplished abstract artist
who married Denise several years ago.
Given his obsession with social
and environmental justice
he convinced the sister
to start Love Queen
shortly after joining the family.
He's the polar opposite of the
typical Beef Queen customer.
- And to be clear,
Love Queen is the philanthropic
arm of Beef Queen,
which is basically designed
to offset all the harm
that Beef Queen does to the world.
Love Queen is kind of trying to like
minimize the carbon footprint
or offset their carbon footprint, right,
so that's the thing that
Maze is in charge of.
But then your character.
- Kevin Pacarkarski.
Pacarkarski.
Two cars.
- Read his district.
- He's Danielle's brand new husband.
He's a small town guy
who was up until recently
just a manager of a Beef Queen in Ohio.
- Now to be clear, we're
talking about the daughter,
the super ambitious daughter
who's the real sort of business mind,
she's so focused on Beef Queen
that she doesn't have time
for someone who's going
to like challenge her
So she needs somebody who's going to do
exactly what she says.
- Danielle fell in love with him
on an episode of "Undercover Boss".
She also became an unintentional meme
for complimenting Kevin
on how he handled his
meat while on the show.
Kevin is remarkably naive about everything
outside of the small town
where he grew up and worked
until marrying Danielle.
He is continuously amazed
by life in the big city.
- Like he hasn't seen an escalator before,
everything is new to him.
- He's incredibly ignorant of all things
that Maze hold sacred,
which infuriates Maze.
Danielle thought it would be a good idea
to have Kevin run Love
Queen along with Maze,
hoping that his Beef Queen
loyalty and apolitical nature
would help take some of the
edge off of Love Queen's
more questionable operators.
- Right, so you've got
this basically sort of
conservative guy that hasn't
experienced a lot of the world
and then you've got this over
the top hippie left-winger
and they have to work together
kind of in the context
of this sub organization
that's the bigger context of
this giant fast food chain.
I still like this idea.
- This is a fun idea.
We pitched this idea to
Adam McKay's company.
- Oh yeah, we did.
- You know, we go into
Adam McKay's office.
- He wasn't there.
- He wasn't there,
but his business partner
and development guy,
I'm sorry I can't remember
his name but, was there
and we had a good conversation.
- Just to be clear, 'cause
I don't want people to be,
- Oh gosh, yeah, we
need to have this aside.
- I want to say this real quick, okay,
sometimes we go out on a limb
and we talk about sort of
things like this, you know,
not private but things that
you didn't know about before.
Like a prime example is
several years ago when
I auditioned to be Taserface
for "Guardians of the Galaxy".
And I told the story of the audition
and all I said was that
the audition went well
and that there was like a
second level of interest.
It wasn't like they just, you know,
I heard through the grapevine that they,
and the director, James
Gunn, liked the audition,
and that's all I said, right.
- And we thought it would
be cool to tell you that.
- That got turned into
someone, one of you,
going on to James Gunn's Instagram page
and commenting on a
completely unrelated post
and asking him the question saying-
- He was answering questions on Twitter.
Now we don't know who made the post.
- I think it was on Instagram.
- If you're starting to
get embarrassed right now
we do not know who you are,
we didn't pay attention
and we're not holding it against you.
And we don't remember your
name so don't sweat it.
- But what you said was, is it true
that Rhett McGlaughlin was the
first choice for Taserface.
At which point James Gunn
literally responds to that
in the comments and says,
no, Chris Sullivan was
always our first choice
although I liked that guy, or whatever.
So he acknowledged.
- So it seems like you were
like saying publicly that like
you turned down the role.
- So now James Gunn thinks that I think
that I was the first choice for Taserface.
That's not what I said
and I regret even and
saying anything about it
but now you're talking
about us going into-
- So don't tweet at Adam McKay
thinking you're doing
us any favors by saying,
you should really do
that "Beef Queen" idea,
he won't know what the
hell you're talking about
and it'll embarrass us.
- Just keep it to yourself, okay?
- And if you want to
know what it feels like
to be our children, this is
how we talk to them sometimes.
Don't embarrass me in public, okay?
And if you want to know
how my kids have to treat me
sometimes, they also tell me,
hey, don't embarrass
me in public sometimes.
- I still like that idea.
- I still like, yeah, it was a fun idea.
I mean, we, you know, you go
around, you meet with people
who you think can produce this thing.
I'm not going to mention the other people
'cause now I'm regretting it.
- And also we didn't, we
just did a write-up for this,
we didn't write the pilot.
And also, and this is something, you know,
this is something that we continue to
debate amongst ourselves and that is,
are we just writing this and
making this or producing this?
Are we doing that and also starring in it?
Obviously with "Buddy
System" we did all that,
but I don't know, the
more time that passes
the more convinced we become
that like, you kind of have to,
I don't know, you kind
of have to make a choice.
So I don't know if you're
going to get into any ideas,
it's more recent that
we've developed ideas
that don't have us being the two,
it doesn't start with two guys.
- Here's some you won't remember.
I'll just read the one, do you
remember a show called "SOS"?
- That was just a log line.
Just begin to read it and
then I'll remember it.
- Two brothers in law
who happened to deeply hate
one another find themselves-
- Oh, um, stranded on an island.
- Marooned on an island
after going overboard during a flight
on a family cruise vacation.
They need overcome their
differences to survive
on this island full of secrets.
Think "Lost" meets "Last Man on Earth".
That was it.
- Yeah and it was going to
be like a surreal comedy.
- "Sunshine Ranch".
- Ooh, um, you gotta
give me the first bit.
- People come to Sunshine Ranch, Sunsign,
to deal with addiction,
but not the typical vices
of drugs, sex, and alcohol.
No, the staff of sunshine
ranch specialize in...
- Oh gosh, I can't remember this.
- Strange addictions.
There's a woman who's attracted
to inflatable furniture.
There's even a dude who's addicted
to staring at his legs in a mirror.
Kurt finds himself sent to Sunshine Ranch
after a family intervention
over his addiction
to new car smell, which has
left him deeply in debt.
- This is a dumb idea.
- He insists he's normal.
Ensemble cast, Rhett
and Link are patients,
or potentially patient slash staff.
- That's a dumb idea.
- Potentially offensive.
- Yeah, it's also like insensitive.
- Wrong minded.
- Yeah.
Yup, not proud of that one.
- Making fun of people's addictions.
I didn't read it to myself
before I read it to everyone.
- No, it's fine, it's
good, we go into places
and you gotta just let
the ideas flow sometimes.
- "Opinionated".
This one starts off, Rhett and Link bond.
I don't even know if this is scripted
Rhett and Link bond over pointing out
what's annoying about other people.
I think that's just a statement,
that's a backstory statement.
This gives them the
idea to start a business
which offers a very simple
yet specialized service.
- I remember this.
- Spend one hour with someone
and then tell them everything
about them that's annoying.
Can their friendship and
business partnership withstand
one another's razor-sharp criticism?
- So the premise for this,
and again, this is not
a developed show idea,
but it is based on the
idea that sometimes,
and this may look make
us look like assholes
and we're not assholes to people directly,
Let me just be honest about
that or just get that out there.
But you know, especially
back before the pandemic
when we actually would
go to social functions
and meet new people,
you know, sometimes
you're like go to a party
and you'll meet somebody
and then we'll begin
to have a conversation
after the party and be
like, did you meet that guy?
Did you meet Kurt?
- Right.
- And it's like, oh yeah.
And did you notice the thing
that he did with his so and so?
- It's more observational
humor, but yeah, it's like,
we like picking people apart
and we also knew that like,
if you took people who
did that to an extreme,
they would be assholes
and they probably couldn't
live with each other.
- And let me be clear, so
Kurt Sutter is a friend,
I'm not talking about Kurt Sutter.
I just used the name Kurt.
- I think Kurt was in the last pitch.
- There's nothing annoying about Kurt.
- All right, let me go to feature ideas.
Okay.
The beast is real.
I definitely remember this one.
This one says 2018.
Two friends are deep in the wilderness,
dead set on locating
a fabled forest beast,
think Bigfoot but cooler.
But it turns out that they're escapees
from a mental hospital,
what, we can't do that.
- But hold on. just to be clear, like,
this is one of those, and I do question
whether or not you can do this anymore
and I realized it was only 2018
that we came up with this idea.
But the idea was that you've
got someone that is wrongfully,
has been wrongfully committed.
- Yeah, I mean, we both been
watching "The Leftovers"
and there's a lot of that going on there.
There's a guy in a, the
dad's in a mental institute.
- It's sort of blurring the idea between,
you know, reality and
fantasy and you're like,
is this person like
certifiable or do, you know?
- It raises the question,
the question from-
- If you say that you've had
an experience with a Sasquatch,
you know, most people think
there's something not
quite right with you.
But these guys have this
commitment to finding this thing
and there's a-
- Their resident psychiatrist Julie,
who has played along with the guys'
imaginative ideas for years,
joins their journey in an
effort to bring them home
safely and unharmed.
When Julia is accidentally
shot by one of them
they must abandon their journey
and bring her to safety.
Things are complicated
when they actually
encounter the beast itself,
boom, spoiler alert!
Tone is comedic, but gripping and real.
Kind of like "Swiss Army Man"
meets "O Brother, Where Art
Thou?" meets "Deliverance".
(Rhett and Link laughing)
- Again, this was not-
- It's just an idea.
Just throw ideas against the board.
- It hasn't been developed.
- We didn't pitch that to anybody.
- No, I don't think we,
yeah, it's got some flaws.
- "Charlie Horse Saves the World".
This was 2018 but this is
something that was percolating
for many years.
The way I remember this
idea starting, and I'm not,
I'll let you share the idea
as much as you remember it
or I can read it,
we had these meetings
with production companies
and I think Paul set this up
way back then where we would go
and we would just have meet
and greet meetings and say,
yeah, we've got a bunch of ideas
but this is more about just
knowing that we're here now.
Look at us Rhett and Link, we're in L.A.
- General meetings.
- Generals they call it.
You go in, you sit in the lobby,
and somebody at it behind
a desk would like to say,
would you like some coffee
or tea while you wait
up to 40 minutes to go back
for this general meeting
that is no one's priority.
And we'd say, sure,
the best thing about it
was getting the drinks and sitting there
and looking at the posters on the wall
of all the stuff they've made.
- And we didn't like, we still
don't like general meetings
because we're like, why
are we talking about
things in general when we can
talk about a specific idea?
And so we just kind of lost our appetite
'cause we were like,
if we were having a general
meeting with somebody,
it's like, well okay, what
are we going to do together?
- We had a few people would
say, do you have any ideas?
And we'd be like, yeah, we're
working on a bunch of stuff.
We can come back to you.
And it felt like we were
like keeping things secret
but we really didn't have any ideas.
- So what we ended up doing that day
is we were looking at
the posters in the lobby,
which, you know, signified the movies
that this particular outfit had worked on,
and we began to pick up on a theme
from some of the movies they worked on.
- Comedy, sci-fi.
- Let's take some of the
genres that we're seeing.
represented in their repertoire
and let's develop an idea.
- Right now sitting on this on this couch.
And then when we went into the room
and they ask us, do you have any ideas?
- We pitched it like we had
come up with it a long time ago.
- We developed this idea five
minutes before the meeting,
then we go into the
meeting and when they say,
you got any ideas, we pitched
the idea and they liked it.
And they were like, okay,
once you start writing that,
come back to us, which is, you know,
now we know is code for, I'll
believe it when I see it.
- Okay, I'll see what I can
remember about this idea,
but I got to tell you,
I still feel like this is a viable idea.
It's just a little bit too big
budget for us at this point.
This might be is if we
actually make a movie
and people like it, but
Charlie Horse is a band,
a band that was popular in the 70s or 80s.
- Southern rock band of the 80s.
I mean, we were thinking Alabama
meets Allman Brothers in the 80s.
- And Charlie Horse is
really good name for a band.
- Yeah, 'cause if you
punch somebody in the leg
they get a Charlie horse.
But the premise was that
NASA had been, you know,
NASA will like broadcast, or
at least the SETI Institute
will like broadcast radio
signals into the universe
to try to say, Hey, here we are.
And presumably there's
music, I know for a fact
that in some instances
there's been music that's been broadcast.
And so the premise of
Charlie horse saves the world
is that their music has been broadcast
since the 70s into space.
- 80s.
- since the 80s into space
and then now-
- the president in the 80s,
the president chose to include
their double platinum album,
"Black Snake Fever" in a radio broadcast
that was transmitted into deep space.
It turns out the broadcast
created some extra terrestrial superfans.
- Do you remember anything else?
- I remember that the
aliens come to Earth.
- Over 30 years later
- And their mission is
to find Charlie Horse,
which incidentally has
disbanded by this point.
And so Charlie or whoever's
in charge of Charlie Horse.
- Probably Horse.
- Has to go and try to assemble the band
and get them back together
so they can save the world.
- Yeah, it's not an easy task
but once the boys get back together
their new songs are so bad
that they offend their alien visitors
who vowed to destroy the planet.
Can Charlie Horse pull off
one last explosive performance
and save Earth?
- I love this idea!
- Yeah, yeah.
- There's definitely something to this.
- Because if you look at 80s era Alabama
they're just such ridiculous characters.
You can see Will Ferrell
playing all of them.
- Well, and we were like,
we can confidently play these characters
but we can also get some
more seasoned comedic actors
to sort of take the lead on this one
we'll just be part of an ensemble.
- what about "Catch and Release"?
- That is a mockumentary
about a famous fishermen
who runs a, like a fishing channel.
And there's a new, like hot shot,
I can't remember exactly what happens
but it's basically a mockumentary
about professional bass fishermen.
- Early 90s, Skeet Nixon and you're, hey,
it's good, you got a good
memory for this stuff.
I mean, when you come up with
it it's easy to remember.
Set in the early 90s,
Skeet Nixon and Dale Dance
are the most popular professional
anglers in the world.
- Yeah, they are.
- Which doesn't mean much.
They each have primetime shows on Fish TV
and they're mortal enemies
that have been locked
in a bitter competition
for over a decade.
When Fish TV's ratings plummet
due to the lack of interest
in professional fishing
a smooth talking reality TV producer
talks Skeet and Dale in a
moving into a house together
to start a reality TV show.
- That's so good!
This still a good idea
- We could make this with no money.
- This is a low budget idea, for real.
This is not "Charlie
Horse Saves the World",
This is something that we
could make for, you know,
it costs a lot of money to make movies
so when we say something like $1 million
you just need to understand
that that's not a lot of money
in the movie world,
but that's a sub $1
million movie right there.
- All right, I definitely remember
when we came up with the
idea to come up with an idea
for a Christmas movie
- I still believe in this.
- We were surfing and then
we went to that restaurant
that overlooked to surf.
And I had on a winter
coat and my swim trunks
and we sat out there and we were like,
we can sit here and come up
with a Christmas movie idea.
And we came up with "The Perfect Gift".
At a loss as to what to
get his wife for Christmas,
a man takes the advice of
his 12 year old stepdaughter
and uses a service that claims to select
the perfect gift for someone
by analyzing their DNA.
Hey, I'm hooked.
When it turns out that the
gift is in fact too perfect,
the man finds himself going to extremes
to get his wife back.
That one got a little fuzzy for me.
- Well, if I recall this one correctly,
because I actually spent,
I actually spent way too much
time on a writeup on this one
that I remember then, you know-
- Stevie ripped to
shreds I think. (laughs)
- No, see, now you're going
to throw Stevie under the bus.
- Hey, I agreed with her.
- Let me just, this is not a good-
- [Siri] Sorry, I can't
hear what you said.
- That scared the crap outta me!
I thought it was Stevie under the table
but it was your freaking.
- I have no problems with being told
that something is not a great idea
and just because we can make
it sound like it's a good idea
to some of you guys, it doesn't
mean that it's a good idea.
Because let me just go
on and tell you that
what ended up happening in this movie was
he gets his wife a power drill.
- Oh yeah, it got really weird.
- And it's like, well, he
got his wife a power drill
and it's like she's never
been into like anything
related to like fixing things up,
you know, this is totally out of-
- Not because she's a
woman or any sexist reason,
just because of who she
is as an individual.
- But there was irony in the
fact that she was a woman
who was suddenly into a power
drill, which I understand-
- Oh, she was into it, that's right.
- No, she was so into it
that she becomes obsessed
with the power drill
and basically, it's kind
of a phallic symbol.
She doesn't have sex with a power drill,
but she becomes so in love
with a power drill and using it
that she's screwing everything
with this power drill
and drilling everything.
- It's kind of like a "Being
John Malcovich" kinda.
- Yeah, and she becomes so
obsessed with this power drill
that then he has to go and meet with,
now, we would never get Jeff Goldbloom
to play this particular
part but we had said,
like Jeff Goldbloom is this
guy who's like a fixer,
he's like a problem solver.
- No, he also sold, he's
the one who told him
to buy or the power drill at first,
but then it works so well
that he has to go back to him.
- Yeah, it's the same guy, so
it's not double mumbo jumbo.
Which I thought we had
just made the mistake.
- No, he goes back to Jeff.
- He goes back to the source.
- To fix it.
- And so he gives him a recipe
for how you undo someone's
love for something
and try to get them back and it involves
playing a song at a certain time.
Like there's a weird, like a scene where
they're on the beach
and he brings a jam box
and he plays "Take On Me"
or something like that?
I don't know, it was a
weird, it was a weird one.
- It did not remain cohesive.
- No, but sometimes you
just gotta keep following,
you gotta following this thing.
- Saint Rick.
This was a lot easier to follow.
- Isn't this essentially
what "The Santa Clause" is?
- Who cares?
- When Santa decides to delegate
his Christmas Eve present delivery
to a collection of regional managers.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This one's gonna get made man,
if you say this, somebody
is going to make this one.
This is a good idea.
- Well, you know what, we're on record.
- Okay.
- An unemployed family man named Rick,
finds himself with the responsibility
of delivering president,
president, I mean presents,
to children across the Southern US.
So he's like, again, we're
going to redneck Rick humor.
- Yeah.
- It's a redneck Santa.
- Yeah, Santa has delegated the
delivery of all his presents
to multiple Santas.
- Southern Santa Rick.
- And Rick has been given the
Southeastern United States.
- That's pretty great, man.
- I still like that one, man.
Saint Rick.
- That's a good one.
- Let's make that, let's make Saint Rick.
See, here's the thing you say.
You think that when we
say that then we can just,
no, we can't just go make it.
You got to get somebody who's like, yes,
I think the Saint Rick is a
great idea for a Christmas movie
and I believe that you guys
can write a great script
and I'm going to give
you this money to do it.
- Yeah, I'm trying to find out, let's see.
- And I will say while Link
is looking for more ideas,
I will say-
- I found 'em.
- That we are actually currently,
just so you know, we are
writing a script for a feature.
- Well, we're not currently
writing it because-
- We haven't broken the
story out completely,
but we have a premise
and we're not going to tell
you anything about the movie,
So we are actively working on a feature
that we were excited about,
but we're also working on-
- A television pilot.
- 19 other things.
- The television pilot's
getting in the way
of the movie script.
- And an unscripted
television idea as well.
And everything else that you see,
so it's, these things take time.
- We're still trying.
- We're throwing a lot
of things at the wall
and we always have.
- All right, this one's
kinda like Charlie Horse
but totally different, an
animated comedy called "Glondor".
- Okay.
- In 1998, the then president
of the United States
commissioned NASA to have a one hour long
Earth TV special broadcast into
deep space, sound familiar?
- This was our lower hanging fruit idea
that worked on the same principle
as "Charlie Horse Saves the World."
- Right, but it's animated.
It was to be a message to any
alien civilizations out there,
a window to life on Earth,
as the president called it.
Of course, the special included
a very narrow swathe of
American pop culture,
including music videos
from the most popular band at the time,
like the Backstreet Boys,
highlights featuring the current NBA MVP,
think Michael Jordan,
clips from movies starring
the blockbuster action hero,
like a Bruce Willis type.
Pictures of the 1998 Sports Illustrated
swimsuit cover model.
- Okay stop, I remember now.
So they send this compilation
of all this 1998 stuff,
like you just said, popular
athlete, popular supermodel,
popular musician, et cetera.
And the same exact thing that happens
in Charlie Horse happens,
an alien civilization becomes
obsessed with these people
and comes to earth but in this version,
because this is an animated
show that needs a story engine,
he kidnaps this alien civilization.
- The ruler of Glondor, Dale,
his Glondorian name is
unpronounceable in Earth languages,
sent a team of Glondorians
to kidnap the earthlings
featured on the broadcast.
Of course they're much older now.
The American celebrities,
more than a decade past their prime,
are essentially prisoners on Glondor
living in a small Earth-like village.
the Glondorian's did the best they could
but they messed up a bunch of details.
And they're forced to hang out
with Dale whenever he wants.
They also make appearances at
important Glondorian events.
They're basically like the royal family.
- The royal family, but they're old
and they can't do any of the
stuff that they used to do.
Like, you know-
- Washed up.
- Pop culture icons.
- D celebrities.
- The next one in the writeup
is "Fairview International"
which became "Unattended Baggage",
and so in this particular document,
that was the second
thing that we put on here
with much less fanfare
is the thing that we ended up developing.
We also had Norman Normal on here.
That was a really old
animated idea we had.
- Norman Normal actually made,
actually went really far down
the rabbit hole with that
because we were working.
- Some producers out of New Zealand
or Australia contacted us in
our basement in Lillington.
- This is long time ago.
- This was like before "Online Nation",
just based on our videos they were like,
you guys are musical, you're comedians,
let's develop something together.
And we were like, well, we have an idea.
Anybody contacts us from
Australia or New Zealand,
we have an idea.
Norman Normal, Norman is totally normal
except for one detail,
he owns a briefcase.
And this is kind of a kid's animated show.
We're thinking more kids back then.
Norman owns a brief briefcase
that contains two pint sized
superheroes, Rhett and Link.
- Hey guys, that's us.
- This might seem useful until
you learn that Rhett and Link
each have a different superpower
every single time Norman
opens the briefcase.
- So Norman would be dealing
with the everyday problems-
- He was a landlord of
an apartment building.
- And so he had like
normal, not sensational,
but just normal problems.
You know, like, oh, there's a flooded pipe
in this apartment complex.
And so he would open up the briefcase
and Rhett would have one superpower
and Link would have another superpower
but it might be something
stupid like well,
Rhett can shoot spaghetti
out of his butt hole
and Link is invisible.
So it's like, okay, what
can I do with spaghetti
and somebody I can't see?
And then he would close
it and open it immediately
and it would be two completely
new novel superpowers.
And he would do that until
he got two super powers
that would help him with
his mundane normal problem.
- Right, and the cool thing was we,
we pitched this and they were like,
we like it, let's do something with it.
And they said, if you don't mind
I could take a stab at
writing, starting the pilot.
And remember, cause they
had written some stuff,
they had produced some stuff.
I think it was on like
Australian television.
- Yeah, I don't remember
many details about this.
- So we kind of trusted 'em
and the dude wrote a pilot
and it was, we were kind of blown away.
We were like, this is crazy.
- Do you have a copy of that?
- I'll look for it.
- And why didn't anything
happen with that?
- Because I think we got cold feet.
Let's see if there's anything, nope,
don't have anything earlier
because I wasn't using,
I didn't move it to my Google Drive.
I could probably find it somewhere.
- It might be on my Dropbox.
- I mean, we've got some unscripted ideas.
I don't want to go through those
because they're more recent,
they're based off of
like spinning off ideas
from "Good Mythical Morning"
into their own shows
that we would host.
That's when "Guesstimaters" came back
as a show we were calling
"The Magic Number."
- Norman Normal draft 1.6 doc.
- Oh, you found it.
- Pilot episode beat sheet draft, 2009.
- 2009, that's crazy.
- Okay, opening title montage.
Montage would be shot as
an action hero show open
from the 70s but slowly anti-climactic,
showing anti-climactic
events, that's great.
Norman is doing very
mundane everyday activities
from brushing his teeth
to minor repairs around
the apartment block.
Rhett and Link are
singing the opening theme.
Each of Norman's mundane tasks
ends with a superpower moment,
mostly bringing a smile to the situation
and a quick cut to Rhett
and Link performing
to acknowledge the origin
of the superpowers.
Let's see if I, oh, yeah,
written by Andrew Horn.
- Shout out to Andrew,
thanks for believing
in us back in the day.
I mean, there's other
stuff we can unearth,
maybe we'll do that at another time,
but like that's pretty much
everything that I had unearthed
that I wanted to talk about.
I mean, I definitely remember
going in for the pitches,
and I do think, like you said,
we can talk more about like
what's the psychological impact
on people who have all
these creative aspirations
like in being rejected so many times?
I mean, and sometimes
things get really far,
like with "Legitimate",
we were sitting in a room
at ABC Network-
- singing a song for them.
- Singing this song and they
like all clapped afterwards.
We were like, that was amazing.
We nailed this song, we were talking about
how Jack Black was going to die
and they were eating
it up and then nothing.
So I propose that, that we pick up,
we talk more about the
existential crisis of rejection
in the next episode.
- So we'll take the next
episode to talk about what
experiencing that level and
that amount of rejection
has done and how that might relate to you
and the things that you're trying to do.
I will say that we live in a weird,
we kind of have a unique
situation because,
again, everything that
we just talked to you
about is something that
a very small, until now,
a very small group of people knew about
and they all had mostly said, no,
we're not interested in
this, but at the same time
we've been able to have enough things work
to be able to make a living
in the entertainment industry
in a very sort of non traditional
sort of figure it out as you go along way
through the digital media and in YouTube.
And so it creates this lots of success
that's sort of fueling
the growth of our company
and being able to have the margin
to develop these traditional ideas
and to get like what you know,
what you might call rewarded
and to be sort of accepted
by this group of people
who have decided that they
liked the things that we create
that have made it into the world.
But at the same time to
have this very long string
of these things that we're
super passionate about
that we're very excited about,
that we're always thinking about
and always trying to develop,
repeatedly told no about those things.
There's a, I mean, again,
what I'm saying is that
some people are just getting
told no all the time.
You're a classic like starving artists who
hasn't had anything work
and is just being told no
and they may be super talented
and may have great ideas.
We have the privilege of having
had success in this one area
that gives us the margin to be
able to develop these things
and then actually have
somebody listen to them
and then be told no.
But it is an interesting thing
that like what has it done
to be told no that many times
and why do we keep going right
back to the drawing board
and believing that we are going
to be able to make something
like one of these things
that we talked about.
We'll talk about that next week.
- For now, now #EarBiscuits if any,
I mean, if you love any of
those and you want to buy 'em,
if you're a network
executive, Hey, #EarBiscuits.
- And I've got a quick rec
that ties directly into this conversation
and especially begins to bleed over
into the conversation
that we'll have next week,
which is something I've
been thinking about a lot.
It's a book that's a very quick read,
very easy read called "Big
Magic" by Elizabeth Gilbert.
Now Elizabeth Gilbert is
the novelist who wrote
"Eat, Pray, Love", which I have to say,
I have not read the
book or seen the movie.
- Me neither.
- But my wife was listening
to or reading this book
and then she was like, I think
he might enjoy this book.
It's like, it's all about,
it's a nonfiction book
and it's all about the creative process
and sort of the approach to creativity.
I mean, one of the most
helpful books that I ever read
in terms of creativity was
the "Artists Way", right,
which I recommend to any creative people.
And I think that big magic is,
you know, it's similar in
that it is super inspirational
and encouraging to you
as a creative person.
And I think one of the
points that she makes
is that everyone is creative,
you don't have to be a
professional creative person
to be creative
and you don't have to be a
professional creative person
to create things and to live
a creative life, as she says.
Anyway, there's a few things
in there that you were like,
okay, I don't know if I believe fully
all the things that you're saying
in some of the things that, you know,
there's sort of a super spiritual
side to the whole thing.
But I think regardless of
where you kind of come down
on that particular aspect of it,
it's one of the most encouraging books
and it's interesting that, you know,
we just went through all these projects
and we're talking about
failure in the next episode
because she tells so many stories
about how to get through that rejection
and people not believing in you
and how so easily you can let
those external expectations
that you tie to your work bring you down
and keep you from getting
through to the next idea
and just the nature of ideas,
anyway, highly recommend it
for anybody who even considers themselves
even possibly a little
bit creative, "Big Magic".
- We'll talk at you next week.
Until then a little magic.
To watch more "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of "Ear Biscuits"
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.
(calm music)